creo que por aquí te podemos escuchar
sigue igual de vigoroso
en unas semanas llegará el bebé de marín
el parto o se hará en su casa de manera
natural junto con su matrona florian es
como si realmente estuviéramos
construyendo lo mismo juntas el vínculo
se crea durante todo el embarazo ante la
menor pregunta ante la menor duda
realmente se pueden hacer preguntas es
como uno quiera
siempre que quieras gracias al parto en
casa estas mujeres reciben el beneficio
de tener un seguimiento con la misma
especialista durante todo su embarazo y
después del nacimiento de su hijo y eso
es lo que florián quería acompañar de
otra manera a las futuras madres
pero estas matronas son poco numerosas
hay alrededor de 80 de las 23.000 que
trabajan en francia cuando una mujer
llega al hospital oa donde su ginecólogo
diciendo que está embarazada es muy raro
que su médico le diga muy bien que le
gustaría experimentar durante su parto
sabe que hay una casa de parto en
nuestro caso está en nancy en un ibi hay
una dependencia técnica hay
posibilidades de dar a luz en casa ya
que de todas maneras hay una reticencia
frente a este tipo de partos naturales y
de hecho ha habido tomas de posiciones
públicas hechas por el colegio de
ginecólogos ellos tienden a decir que
hay que evitar dar a luz de esa manera
un mes después de nuestra visita marín
dio a luz a su hijo
justo después del parto florian realiza
los mismos exámenes que se hacen en una
sala de maternidad
[Música]
y si todo está bien como es el caso de
marín y su hijo todos se quedan en casa
hola hola
hola la primera semana después del
nacimiento
la matrona va todos los días examinará
al bebé y a la mamá luego espacio a sus
visitas
hace unos días morgan dio a luz a la
pequeña ali yo estaba ahí con morgan de
rodillas y valentín que estabas ahí
delante y te dije que estirar a sus
manos para pasarte la toalla
y al final ella estaba ahí morgan pudo
dar a luz en su casa porque su embarazo
era de bajo riesgo en nueve meses no
desarrolló ninguna patología no estaba
embarazada de mellizos y vivía a menos
de 45 minutos de una sala de maternidad
estábamos los tres y no había nadie ahí
que nos dijera cómo debíamos hacerlo en
realidad todo se hizo de manera natural
y todo se hizo oficial ella no dejaba de
cambiar de posición pero por qué era lo
que le resultaba más cómodo y si uno lo
piensa en el hospital hay una sola
posición y nada más como no tenemos
restricciones ni tiempos limitados ni
otras mujeres que atender respetamos el
ritmo de la familia a causa de las
restricciones por el cob y si morgan o
hubiera dado a luz en un hospital
valentina habría tenido que irse al cabo
de unas horas después del nacimiento de
su hija
y eso no era una opción no sé si lo
hubiéramos hecho pero ahora que lo
intentamos ya no lo dejaremos
al igual que familia y si los felices
padres de maría
todo se hizo tranquilamente con florian
a su lado
todo estaba asegurado ella llegó aquí
con todo el material necesario para el
parto en casa además habíamos acordado
que si llegaba a haber la menor
preocupación el menor riesgo
seríamos transferidos al hospital si así
es estamos a cinco minutos del hospital
todo estaba previsto una mujer que
decide dar a luz en su casa debe de
todas maneras ir a una sala de
maternidad para tener un expediente en
los que estemos en contra del parto en
un hospital o en contra de la epidural o
lo que sea es simplemente que nosotros
queríamos hacer un parto en casa y así
como lo dijo civil da tranquilidad saber
que en caso de un problema se puede ir a
un hospital
pase lo que pase ellos saben quiénes
somos tienen un expediente con nuestros
nombres según la asociación de matronas
a domicilio en 2019 en francia el 11 por
ciento de las futuras madres que tenían
previsto dar a luz en su casa fueron
transferidas al hospital durante el
trabajo de parto dar a luz de manera
natural también puede hacerse en una
casa de parto pero para poder existir
debe estar vinculada a una sala de
maternidad aquí estamos en la zona de
partos
casa de parto y detrás de esta puerta se
accede directamente al ascensor a los
dos ascensores que están aquí y que
suben a la dependencia técnica del
hospital blue es una casa de parto al
igual que el parto en casa y como todas
las alternativas existe porque hay
hospitales porque la transferencia hace
parte de la normalidad de un nacimiento
por fuera del hospital y hace parte de
su seguridad es un procedimiento normal
que nunca entonces trabajamos juntos y
es evidente que en francia es necesario
que todo exista
aquí en calma cuyas iniciales significan
como en la casa nacen alrededor de 130
bebés cada año dos tercios de las
solicitudes son rechazadas por falta de
cupos el tema sea agradable con esas
ventanas grandes hay una cama de verdad
está la bañera con el mosaico es muy
bueno la razón por la cual no vinimos
aquí para mi primer embarazo era porque
en realidad no lo conocíamos ni siquiera
sabíamos que esto existía la calidez del
lugar y la bondad de las seis matronas
que trabajan aquí fue también lo que
atrajo a elodie y pierre
su primer hijo nació en calma para ellos
era evidente que sería igual para el
segundo
yo lo que realmente quería era tener
algo muy personalizado y sobre todo
estar en un ambiente donde me sintiera
segura y para mí la seguridad es conocer
a las personas que van a estar ese día a
mi alrededor poder confiar en ellas
al igual que para el parto en casa para
poder dar a luz en calma el embarazo
debe ser de bajo riego él y su esposo
evaluaron los pros y los contras una
decisión largamente pensada pero muy a
menudo criticada si estamos hablando de
ti
los especialistas me dijeron cosas muy
duras me dijeron que estaba loca que las
mujeres como yo querían dar a luz en la
selva en realidad es difícil que un
médico diga algo así
y lo que pienso es que el cuerpo médico
no está nada sensibilizado ante esta
situación ni a darnos información al
respecto unas horas después del parto la
pareja y el bebé pueden irse a su casa
al principio la matrona está disponible
las 24 horas del día e irá a verlo
varias veces durante los días después
del nacimiento siempre soñé con tener
tiempo para hacer mi labor en el
hospital siempre tenía la sensación de
estar tarde y de no tener el tiempo para
hacer las cosas bien en calma
encontré colegas con los que descansamos
siempre tenemos preguntas siempre
reflexionamos sobre nuestras prácticas
porque hacemos las cosas porque
decidimos no hacer las cosas entonces
tengo la impresión de estar volviendo a
hacer mi trabajo de manera inteligente
después de 5 años de experimentación el
senado votó en noviembre de 2020 un
artículo de ley que mantiene las casas
de parto
actualmente existen 8 en francia se
deberían crear otras 12 para el 2022